Yeah. Yeah. That's a, that's a
whole nother TJ things. Oh bummer.
That's a bummer. If you don't
know what we're talking about.
Tj Dillashaw tested
positive for injectable EPO,
which is a serious performance
enhancing substance.
And in some circumstances,
according to Jeff Novitsky,
it's given people strokes.
Um, and I had heard this too,
that like young guys doing like Tour
de France type shit would have strokes
because they were taking too much apo.
Cause you know,
like if you're supposed to take one, take
two, fuck it. [inaudible] right, right,
right. That's the mentality.
This mentality's anybody
who's going to do that. Yeah.
You know, I shit turns your, your, your
blood to paint. And I think that's what,
I guess that's probably the
discipline might have held,
people were always getting
away with things beforehand,
right. Is to try to, uh,
maybe try to do it in a way where they
won't get caught. But I think that's like,
Oh, if this much is good and this is much
more, it's going to be better. And Yeah.
And we know guys who've done
that with TRT. You know,
there was a few our t tests where they,
when tea,
our tea was legal testosterone
replacement therapy. Um,
where you would hear about guys tests
and like 14 hundreds, 14, 70, like,
which is insane.
It's like superhuman.
No person has ever lived that as 1400,
uh,
like as a natural walking
around testosterone level.
That's crazy. Hyper human.
But they just get these benefits from
that with some of these people though who
walk around naturally. I wonder if they'd
never been tested though. That's true.
Yeah. Some of these people I see
walking around like genetic freaks do.
Looks like he was born on steroids.
Yeah. There are some freaks, man.
There's some legit genetic freaks to deny.
That would be crazy.
There's some people that just like,
Yo, all Ramiro. What in the fuck?
It doesn't matter how
many steroids you take.
It doesn't matter what you
do like to do look like that.
You have to be a genetic freak. Yeah.
They're out there walking around.
It's not fair. Who you'll always talking
about. He would say go to Cuba. Yeah.
Jeans, go see the jeans. What
have you been look around? Yeah.
What's his name? Um, think
a fighter from France,
the heavyweight from France.
I mean he presents in Ghana for Francis
in Ghana was a guy who used to be the
one who had the, the crazy
fat would pat. Pat Barry. Oh,
we Congo check Congo.
Oh yeah. Adonis. Yeah.
Sculpted Greek statue.
Yeah.
He's just always imagine like I want
to go to where he comes from. What,
let's just take a look around.
Probably super athletes.
Probably a lot of
mediators. Um, the TJ thing,
apparently they went and
tested his old fight.
A piss with Cody too.
And that tested positive for EPO as well.
And then Cody started freaking out. Yeah,
that's right. What do you do if they,
if they go back, like what did they
decide to go back? Hey and say fuck it,
let's test all the fights and it finds
out that he was doing it like five,
six, seven fights. What do do well, yeah.
And then what do you do if you,
uh,
but then that's a whole
nother can of worms too.
Because like all the fights and then
what about all the, because right,
like when we get a test,
everybody,
Chad Brenton job and I were joking around
last night and I was like test them
all and he's going, no, no, didn't
test them all. Test everything.
Let's find out, let's know what it was,
let's know what it was. And he's like,
what if they had pissed samples
from you know, 10 years ago,
15 years ago.
Like what if they could use you sada
style testing today from the past.
I'm so glad that all these
things are above my pay grade
to deal with that. Yeah.
Yeah man.
If I was the guys in the office
right now in charge of that program,
you have to really
wonder where is the line.
You certainly want to test a guy for
a fight that happened a week ago.
You certainly want to hold,
you know and check is if some
new testing methods come out.
If there was a fight from a year ago,
you certainly would check that.
How many years back do you
go though? Yeah, especially
if it's not expensive. Like,
what if it's easy and cheap to do a
test run 500 tests in the last 500
championship fights and then you have
like 400 fights that you now have to like
change the result of
yeah,
I dunno. I Dunno either. Yeah.
Last night I was joking around,
I was saying testimonial.
I was, I was taking the,
the fun position test a mall.
I Dunno.
I mean look,
we all know at one point in
time performance enhancing
drugs were a huge part of
mixed martial arts and that's why the
UFC stepped up and decided to institute
this program.
There's a big part of it.
I think it's a big part of professional
sports in general. Sure. 100%. Yeah.
And I think that, um, you know,
uh, combat sports, you know,
has a government oversight
that other sports don't have.
So I think that we're kind,
we're going to be,
it's going to be coming up regardless
anyway. So I think maybe that's why the,
you know, to the UFC took a
position, right? Because I
think of the other sports.
I mean guys,
you get caught doing things,
but a lot of the other sports regulate
themselves, right? Yeah. I don't know.
I think the NFL regulates itself.
What are those core has?
What does this board has a government
body like athletic commission saying, Hey,
we're going to show up and do
this or do that. I don't know.
Like what do they do with
baseball? I don't know. I don't
know. Maybe. I don't know.
I don't know much about other
sports, but I didn't. I've heard of,
I've never heard, I've never heard
of like a, we all know about we,
you know that's something different.
Our support, the government involved
have a commission would not, not, not
like he's saying a government commission,
but they just, yeah, they're governing
themselves. The NFL would have a vote.
They hand down the suspension.
They're not fair from this.
This guy suspension at that
guy's suspension and baseball.
They have like a three strike rule.
Like that first time is like somewhere
in the 10 to 25 game range and then the
second one is like half the season.
Third one out for a whole year
and if you do it again, your
band, there's no outside getting it shows
up and decides to test your champion.
Right. Just the baseball or
NFL or basketball and the side.
What's the best?
You have a big moneymaker in your
sport and then somebody outside of your
company just comes along and says,
yeah, I'm, I'm the government by,
they have the right to test this guy.
Yeah. Like what happened with John Jones?
Yeah. I mean that's,
that's a perfect example.
I mean the UFC did not want
John Jones to test positive.
He is the biggest star right now other
than Connor and Connor is not active and
Jon Jones is fighting all the time.
He wants to fight all the time.
That if there that's,
but that's the only way you ever find
out what's really going on is you hire a
bunch of werewolves and he just
let them loose. Right. Go check,
Piss, go, go out there,
check, check everyone.
They checked the shit out of people.
I was looking at this list of people
that Holly Holmes been tested more than
like, I think, I think
Novitsky might've put it, oh,
Steve paid meo chick tweeted it because
he'd been tested 38 times. Really? Yeah.
Some people, it's like in the forties,
cris Cyborg got tested a lot. Yeah.
And Holly Holm got tested a lot, Huh?
Yeah. Yeah. Holly Holm got tested. A lot.
Lot of people get tested.
Um, it's just, uh,
like crazy numbers and a lot of them
are guaranteed their waking them up,
you know, get 'em up like six in the
morning. This is what I've heard. I mean,
I don't know what they go by.
I've heard conversations a little bit is,
doesn't seem like it's, no, they
want to make sure you're there.
So they get there really early
in the morning and fucked up.
Tell him where you're supposed to, where
you're going to be at and think, yeah.
Yeah. The problem is if you're training
hard, that eight to 10 is so huge.
You might get hit with a punch.
If they wake you up after
like six hours or five hours,
it's possible that a punch my connect on
you that wouldn't have connected if you
got eight that's not brash.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's real.
That's real. That's real.
Everybody knows when you, how you
feel good in the gym and everybody,
even if you just lift weights,
there's days you feel good days.
Daisy feel like crap. I made sure
I showed up here. Well rested,
you look well rested and I'm hydrated.
I'm like, can we get bathroom? I did.
I did hydrate. Yeah. I mean,
I don't know. It's just,
it's,
it's just not smart to stop athletes in
the middle of their training camp and
wake him up.
Yeah.
I mean I get the testing but I feel
like the testing so sophisticated,
you could get to them at noon. Okay.
Just so you could get to them at noon.
You got good testing now. So we
don't we, I mean I don't know that.
I don't know that either. I'm talking
shit cause I think the best time, right?
That best time is that, you know, maybe
the early years earlier the better. Right.
Maybe, I don't know. The thing
about this EPO apparently,
and this was a shop was telling
me was that they didn't,
it didn't use to be a detectable
the way it is now. They've,
they've got these new methods of
detection and a eps one to that.
Apparently from what I've read, don't
listen to me, I'm not a doctor. Um,
they can absolutely tell
that you injected it. It's a,
it's injectable. It comes
in the injectable form.
That's what's in the bottle.
So there's no chance of a tainted steroids
or tainted, um, a supplement. Right,
right. It's definitely EPO.
So that's, that's fucked up.
Cause apparently that stuff
has a giant advantage. Um,
it gives you an anabolic advantage.
It also gives you crazy
recoup recuperative powers.
So like you could train really hard
and then be ready to go the next day.
What do you think the
answers cause like for me,
like this is all stuff that like,
to be honest,
I don't really pay that much
attention to it because I don't have,
I always say it's out of
my wheelhouse to deal with.
But also it's hard to have an answer.
Like you said,
like do we go back and keep testing
them when these new things come and says
what do we do with the history
to haul? Yeah. Yeah. It's just,
it's very interesting. You know, what
do you do with the history books?
That's what you'd say.
Look at what point if,
if you have samples that
date back 10 years too,
you do chest them all like what do you do?
I don't know.
I don't know how long they keep samples
or how, who has them or how they,
you know, what's the chain of command? Um,
I don't know man.
It's just,
but if you find out that TJ tested
positive for the Cody fight too, well,
Cody shirt has an argument there.
And what if it's the fight before that?
What if you took a lot of that was
a lot of people have arguments.
There's a lot of guys. Yeah. So
it's, yeah, it's, it's tough.
To me it's a shame too because I'm a
Tj fan and I think he's a phenomenal
fighter and a, I'm, I'm a big
fan of watching him perform.
Um, but just, it taints
his legacy. It just does.
There's no way around it
when you get caught cheating,
which is this stuff is,
there's no way it's not cheating.
I mean this is just cheating, right?
I mean this isn't any accident. It's,
it taints your legacy right there. And
the guy had an amazing legacy, you know,
two times bantamweight champion,
one of the best pound for pound fighters.
The way he beat Hanan Barao I was like,
Holy Shit.
Did he went out and fought Hanan Barao he
was sparring with, yeah. Yeah. His stuff,
the stuff, some of his fights
were amazing. He's amazing. Yeah.
It doesn't take away from the fact that
he's amazing. Tj is an amazing fighter.
But fuck man,
that to test positive for EPO.
And the Henry. So Hutto funding is
also crazy to watch the progression,
all the work he did and how much, you
know, he was getting better every fight.
And so he came to this. Yeah, but
you got to think like how much,
like if you're on EPO,
how much does that really
allow you to train extra time?
How much does that allow you to recover?
What's the benefit?
Like what is the quantifiable benefit?
And it must be pretty significant
because there's a lot of, you know,
the cyclists, a lot of heavy
duty endurance athletes use it.
Yeah. I almost want to try it. You know,
they say that these executives are trying,
they're doing EPO and entering into
triathlons and shit like that for bragging
rights. Yeah, just assholes,
assholes with money or take an EPO.
Like really I was reading the thing
about an epidemic of a really a boost you
that much like,
okay,
you're going to take it and you're going
to notice that you're able to like,
like the other day you could barely finish
a role, a loop around the rose bowl,
a three mile loop. And then you started
taking it and you can get what, five,
six miles in. I wonder. I wonder.
I think what it does is it raises your
threshold if you're already an elite
insurance athlete too.
I think for them that's what it is.
It's like they're already
looking for that extra edge.
So they're already in elite endurance
athletes are already in the Tour de France
and they take that EPO and it's
like, whoa, just just Jackson mom.
They could just do more work. They have
more oxygen, they don't run out of juice.
And for a guy like Tj, his style is
so kinetic. There's so much movement,
explosion, switching stances.
Like he needs that juice.
It's not like a calm, easy game where
he's, you know, everything is fast,
fast, fast, fast, fast.
It's crazy. It's hard. It's,
it's a hard one to swallow. Yeah,
man. So for me, like I was like, man,
I was to come on Joe Rogan's
show and let's see, what was he?
Could he talk about to
make me uncomfortable to
talk about maybe some hard
stoppages? Man, I've talk
about some hard stop at, just
give me what's the wars went a little,
let me talk about when I made a mistake.
I don't want to talk about this.
You know what I'm talking about? No,
I'm just being, I have no answer for it.
I don't understand that. It's like, oh,
I'd want to like,
I just doesn't feel like a
good conversation because
all I could do is just,
it just get,
like you said,
it's just going to take away from what
I've seen of Athens and the more I
imagine about it,
it's just going to be more takeaway and
then anything I could say or think about.
I can't think of anything. That
solution or our sister. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. I don't think anybody,
I mean I think we're in this stage right
now where they're probably looking at
the data going,
okay,
what does this signify and how many more
people should we test? You know, once,
once they develop a new method of testing,
that's the whole reason why they want to
keep the old samples anyway in case new,
more sensitive methods of
detecting are invented.
And you know about this stuff
because I know the truth.
You're a science freak and you're saying,
especially,
especially when it comes to
anything that can enhance the,
this life that we have on this earth.
So yeah,
I'm sure you know a lot about this stuff.
While I've had a really
amazing conversation with um,
many people about it and,
uh, David Sinclair was one
more recent ones who did, uh,
this discussion about life extension
and different, uh, anti aging,
uh, solutions and different things
that they're coming up with.
But what I've come through with is at
the other end is there are probably
hundreds of thousands of people that
are involved in either legitimate
supplements or molecules or
testing hormones on people or,
you know,
trying all these different things to
try to figure out how to get the body to
perform better.
Some of them are legal and some of them
are illegal and that's where it gets
strange. She get like the guy, like the
ball co Guy Vic to contact comes along.
It's like, live, I've got one. You just
rub it on. No one's gonna know shit.
They don't even know what this stuff
is yet. Uh, and for a while, yeah,
that worked then, but, but [inaudible]
but while it worked, everybody was like,
hm, why is Barry bonds getting so big? You
know, people just started wrecking like,
mmm, come on man, look at me.
Sammy Sosa, look at me in the eye.
What are you doing?
You know? And they all,
they all like exhibited these obvious
physiological changes where the,
you could tell them whatever they
were doing was really effective stuff.
There's hundreds of thousands of
people working on that right now,
all the time on all the time
trying to get it better.
There's probably thousands of people that
are trying to come up with stuff that
sneaks past this testing.